on this - Greg I remember so you don't
have to I'm sorry I know I don't look my
best enough shaving or anything but it
just cuts so close to Christmas I mean
you're so freaking close I just want get
this video done with it all get okay mmm
without further ado welcome to another
edition of what you never knew I'll
scrub let's just finish this oh so I can
celebrate Christmas with all the famous
Christmas specials out there let's take
a look at one of my favorite National
Lampoon's Christmas vacation all three
families gone through something similar
to what this family had to go through
well okay maybe not exploding a flaming
Santa and reindeer into the sky twice
but everybody can find something to
connect them we've all seen this movie a
million times but nevertheless there's
still probably a few little touches you
might have missed they're not behind the
scenes they're just all the little
details happening right in front of you
that you possibly never realized before
and we're going to take a look at them
here today so let's make a classic even
more classic let's take a closer look at
National Lampoon's Christmas vacation
we all notice eddie putting a ton of
groceries in Clark's basket but if you
ever noticed waste destroying in the
process smooth cameo time there kind of
okay these aren't gigantic names or
anything but there's still people you'll
probably recognize for example Clark's
boss is Bill Murray's brother the
next-door neighbor is Julia
louis-dreyfus the director of the movies
on the cover of the magazine the
daughter is Juliette Lewis and you might
recognize the son from a little show
called Big Bang Theory or deep black
faces a lot of my fans like to call it
and how about the mother from Everybody
Loves Raymond speaking of mothers Andy's
wife is the Tasmanian devils mother from
the 90s show Tasmania which is fitting
seeing how there's a Taz mug earlier
this is neut sister from alien and
Bethany is the voice of Betty Boop as
well as olive oil and her husband is the
scientist from The Nightmare Before
Christmas man this cast has been in
everything Park that's the gift that
keeps on givin the whole year if you
look closely you can see that Eddie's
turtleneck under his sweater is
literally just the neck as it seems he
couldn't afford the rest of the outfit
just can't believe you're actually
standing here in my living room Eddie
but don't let that distract on the fact
that the glass is that drinking out of
our Walley world glasses a call back to
the theme park in the first film you
really think it matters Eddie the
Griswold house is so falling apart you'd
swear it looked like the top of a set
wait a minute
clucks gift to his boss is so unoriginal
that's literally the exact same size and
shape as all the other gifts he's got
but maybe that's because he's deserving
of as much time as he gives to everyone
else the turkey they're having is so bad
that not only are the people having a
hard time chewing it but Ellen subtly
flings it off her for pretending to eat
it it goes by real fast blink and you
miss it hey I thought that slim was
clear at the bottom remember don't try
this at home kids I am a professional a
lot of people miss it but after Ellen's
mother says she has hemorrhoids Ellen
tries her best not to burst out laughing
I imagine that was done a lot in this
movie that's all part of the experience
honey
a lot of stuff is happening when
everybody freezes at the end but
probably the funniest is Eddie's wife
trying to block him like a human shield
and LM protecting Clark's balls like
that's the most important part not to
get shot off well at least we know they
have a healthy sex life sort of the
power company apparently so rarely uses
their auxilary power that's actually
spelled wrong good to know Clark finally
got them down there to see it at least
once never feeling the shaky top of the
railing is a no Maj - it's a Wonderful
Life with the railing that always fell
off in Jimmy Stewart's home the only
exception is where Stewart finds joy in
the imperfection Clark shows it up by
making it even more imperfect
Eddie's son kind of predicts the next
film as the next one is going to be set
in Vegas and that's where Eddie's family
ends up living I guess that'll make up
for the fact that he has literally no
lines in the movie every time the
doorbell rings with the extended family
on the other side the doorbell gets
slower emphasizing the impending doom
that's about to consume them tis the
season to be merry well that's my name
oh shit
Clark's boss never gets his name right
hmm Clark don't forget that report bill
yes sir
Carl what an asshole
even though they say it's the family's
first kidnapping this is not only their
second after the cop from the first
movie but it's also the second vacation
where they killed a pet head authorities
called in being held at gunpoint and yet
somehow they're lucky enough not to have
charges pressed against them
I guess this family has all the luck hey
I know yeah holy shit the dog drinking
the tree water could very well be the
reason the tree explodes from the cigar
after all it would have to be especially
dry in order for that to happen and the
dog from day one is caught doing that
you thinks the water out of there the
trees gonna dry up food for thought
or rather water for thought and the
number one thing you never knew about
National Lampoon's Christmas vacation is
Clark's father-in-law is the first one
to stand up in support of him against
his boss this may seem like a small
thing but really think about it this guy
is easily the biggest complainer and
critic of Clark's abilities he pitches
and makes fun of him throughout the
entire film you're goofy don't piss me
off art a little lights are not
twinkling Dino Arden thanks for noticing
so him being the first one to stand up
and be on his side is actually a big
emotional moment that a lot of people
miss he didn't need any coaxing from
anybody he just stood up to show he
acknowledges that Clark deserves more
than what he's being given it's actually
a pretty powerful moment that a lot of
people don't take notice of it may be
subtle or once you see it you could
actually consider it one of the best
scenes in the movie but luckily there's
enough emotion labs clever writing great
acting and just all around Christmas
goodness to keep this classic and
undying classic it's definitely a
Christmas tradition worth watching again
and again
are there any that we missed are there
any other little touches worth
mentioning well bring them up in the
comments below and have a merry fucking
goddamn Christmas go celebrate have fun
by God is the greatest time of the year
I'm the Nostalgia Critic I remember
that's fine